we begin this half-hour with lessons
learned from Tuesday's shooting rampage
in the rural Northern California town of
Rancho Tehama five people were killed
when a gunman opened fire at several
locations one was an elementary school
where one child was wounded others were
injured by broken glass Jamie yuccas sat
down with the school superintendent
who's reflecting on how his staffs
training many saved many lives
the tragic scenes are too familiar a
gunman shooting up a school leaving
everyone heartbroken Columbine High
School in 1999 Virginia Tech in 2007
Sandy Hook Elementary in 2012 but this
week when a man with a gun started
firing at Rancho Tehama elementary
school the outcome was different we
didn't have a body count we didn't have
one of those headlines that we see all
over the nation and a crazed shooter
bent on evil failed and that's the
victory that victory took practice
school district superintendent Rick
Fitzpatrick believes it was repeated
drills at his school that saved lives
it's something we've been doing in
schools for years now and we take it
very seriously when the school secretary
heard gunshots nearby she immediately
signaled students to get off the
playground and hide under their desks we
didn't have macho warriors that stood up
against a shooter we had men and women
who dug deep in their heart and found
some strength to do the right thing and
be selfless and protect those kids yes
first and second grade teacher Jennifer
Bauman helped the kids get to safety we
did what we're trained to do and our job
is to protect those kids
and they did something that was out of
the norm before him and they're the
heroes one six year old Alejandro
hernández remains hospitalized after
being shot through his classroom wall
he weighs heavy in my heart right now
Hernandez is expected to be ok in all
there were seven crime scenes
the two neighbors killed had feuded with
the shooter in the past and were shot
returning home from dropping a child off
at the school family member Lesley Estes
thinks that's why the gunman headed
there yeah went to school my guaranteed
25 minutes of Terror
has left the town of about 1500 people
grieving those injured and killed ranged
in age from 6 to 68 I'm not saying that
we have the lock on how to fix school
violence and I honor those who have lost
I have a real special place in my heart
and I understand it I was that close to
having it happen but I do think that we
need to focus on hope because I think
that hope and love and care for our kids
and high professionalism will defeat
evil every time for CBS this morning
Saturday Jamie yuccas Rancho Tehama